[Aplausos]
boa tarde
é eu queria contar um pouco sobre a
minha história é eu vou falar sobre um
elemento que me ajudou muito nesse
processo de descoberta do meu propósito
e da minha identidade e esse elemento
vocês acabaram de me ver
colocando na cabeça é o turbante
é bom pra falar de identidade é preciso
explicar pra vocês né o conceito da
identidade a partir da filosofia
contemporânea
a identidade é o entendimento do nosso
corpo aqui no presente no espaço no
tempo a partir das nossas crenças do
nosso conhecimento global ea nossa
capacidade de realizar isso tudo é
sempre individual mas com relação ao
outro e essa é a beleza de se ter uma
identidade é ser o único porque a sua
identidade
ela é sua ela é única identidade do
outro é dele é única
a minha busca começou a partir dessa
conexão com algo que não era tão claro
pra mim em 2012
eu morava em nova york e ali eu passei
por um momento muito delicado na minha
vida é eu passei por um por violência
doméstica e eu estava me recuperando
daquele momento não é tão vulnerável e
tão pesado e um a família de um amigo
meu falou falar me convidou para ir numa
festividade no feriado e eu fui sem sem
esperar nada daquilo
a partir do momento que eu cheguei nessa
festa e eu vi aquelas mulheres negras
maravilhosas com turbantes lindas na
cabeça
aquilo me
emocionou de uma forma muito peculiar
porque como a minha vulnerabilidade ela
era tão densa né
a minha tristeza é tão aparente aquilo
causou uma fagulha de energia e aí eu
perguntei pra matriarca da família sim
seria um desrespeito é e usar um
turbante e ela respondeu que não e ela
foi logo buscar um tecido e me ensinou
na a fazer e assim que eu coloquei
aquilo eu me senti tão forte
eu me senti tão renovada e não tem
sentido pra mim naquele momento mas me
fez buscar me fez buscar a minha
identidade que pra mim até aquela aquela
aquele encontro com aquela família
nigeriana da tribo yorubá era muito
turva era muito nebulosa
eu como mulher negra eu sei muito bem o
que é não saber de onde eu vim né
se eu pergunto pra qualquer amigo meu é
de sobrenome italiano alemão sobre as
origens dele ou dela
eles vão responder com certeza toda a
árvore genealógica da família e no meu
caso é difícil saber quem são os meus
tataravós porque provavelmente eles
trabalharam quase sem remuneração de
forma precária ou foram escravizados e
esse passado não é divulgado aqui no
brasil ninguém fala sobre isso é
vergonhoso falar sobre isso
então a minha identidade era vergonhosa
para mim
a partir do momento que esse elemento
entrou na minha vida
conexão muito forte com quem eu sou de
verdade e este momento é um momento
crucial assim foi um divisor de águas
para mim porque eu fiz muitas perguntas
né e eu quero fazer um paralelo entre a
minha história ea história da uerj né se
sentir vulnerável se sentir né no limbo
se sentir desvalorizado sentir que que
uma que uma sociedade inteira está
tentando tite oprime
se botar sabe se esconder ou não touch
dando os recursos pra brilhar para ser o
seu melhor para entender a sua
identidade de forma positiva
isso tudo eu tiro da minha história
pessoal mas eu entendo que faz sentido
quando a gente se entre olha aqui nessa
sala e quando eu conheci o presidente
obama e o nelson mandela foi numa
ocasião de uma viagem à áfrica do sul
estava em johanesburgo quando isso
aconteceu foi realmente um choque para
mim porque a imaginação pessoas
referência mundial de liderança ponto
e eu ali na presença daqueles líderes
mundiais não é o que se passa na cabeça
de uma pessoa num momento desse
é eu me sentir muito com eu percebi
muita humildade nessa interação eu
entendi que a partir de uma frase que o
presidente obama disse pra mim que é uma
frase do filme do homem aranha com
grande poder vem uma grande
responsabilidade
a partir daquela frase eu entendi que a
minha responsabilidade aqui agora era
entender o melhor que eu pudesse
a minha ideia
idade encontrar um propósito dentro
daquilo por que viver sem propósito é
viver apagado viver sem brilho ea partir
do momento que essa conexão ela
aconteceu
primeiro essa busca nem as perguntas e
as respostas que foram vindo a partir
das perguntas que eu questionei que eu
fiz foram me levando essas a essas
conexões a esses encontros e eu sou
poliglota eu falo quatro idiomas
já viajei o mundo porém diversos países
eu tenho uma multiplicidade de talentos
e eu nunca soube o que eu queria de fato
fazer então eu comecei a fazer tudo o
que eu gostava e foi muito interessante
porque as pessoas sempre olhava pra mim
com aquele olhar de estranhamento né
mas você não trabalhava com moda um
trabalho com turbante
mas você também é intérprete me ajuda
também é atriz e aí você apresenta sim a
minha resposta é assim porque eu sou ser
que dentro da minha identidade
eu tenho múltiplas atividades ea
múltiplas características que me
constituem como o ser humano como
indivíduo como um corpo no tempo e no
espaço
e porque não explorar os meus interesses
dentro de tudo isso e fazer essas
conexões de forma que isso fortalece
fortaleça a minha identidade e me faça
melhor
nem passa múltipla e eu aceitei essa
multiplicidade
a partir desse encontro de conexão com
essa má nela foi muito interessante
porque na época que eu fui visitar a
áfrica do sul ele estava doente no
hospital e teve a oportunidade de ir no
hospital em participar da festividade de
aniversário dele de 95
o anos que foi o último ano que ele teve
aqui na terra em 2013 e foi muito
emocionante porque ali eu entendi a
presença de um ser humano que não
bastava é simplesmente analisar toda a
trajetória dele de forma fria de forma
pontual
eu entendi que só a presença daquele
indivíduo já transformava as pessoas
naquele naquele ambiente e isso me fez
descobrir que essa também é uma
característica minha então todas essas
conexões que eu fui fazendo e aceitando
essa multiplicidade em mim
foram me levando a momento de descoberta
eu queria ler pra vocês eu queria ler
pra vocês uma poesia que o nelson
mandela declamou quando ele teve seu
discurso de posse em 1994
é uma poesia da mary any orleans que
está traduzida nesse caso
nosso maior medo não é o de sermos
incapazes
nosso maior medo é descobrir que somos
muito mais poderosos do que pensamos é
nossa luz e não às nossas trevas
aquilo que mais nos assusta vivemos nos
perguntando quem sou eu que me jogo tão
insignificante para aceitar o desafio de
ser brilhante sedutora talentosa
fabulosa
na verdade por que não procurar ser
medíocre não vai ajudar em nada o mundo
os nossos filhos não existe nenhum
mérito em diminuir nossos talentos
apenas para que os outros
não se sintam inseguros ao nosso lado
nascemos para manifestar a glória do
divino que está em todos nós e não em
apenas poucos eleitos
quando tentamos mostrar essa glória
inconscientemente damos permissão para
que nossos amigos possam também
manifestava quanto mais livres formos
mais livres tornar tornamos aqueles que
nos cercam
a partir dessa poesia eu queria
perguntar pra vocês alunos da uerj o
qual livre vocês se sentem nesse espaço
de aprendizado e o quanto vocês exploram
essa multiplicidade de talentos que
existem aqui e como vocês criam a partir
dessa multiplicidade e de todas essas
conexões que são possíveis dentro dessa
multiplicidade momento de descoberta
momentos de de criação em momentos de
aceitação que todo esse potencial
ele existe e ele existe na identidade
individual de vocês de cada um de vocês
e isso vai se refletir num coletivo a
partir do momento que essa busca
individual ela for contínuo não existe
um fim existe o processo
o processo é isso
o processo sons somos nós dentro de um
universo que é mardy infinito de
possibilidades que nós podemos explorar
e nos dar permissão para explorar a
partir do entendimento da nossa
identidade e ali encontrar um propósito
dentro daquilo
acabou que em 2015
a empresa me convidou para ser é uma das
participantes de um documentário chamado
brasil dna áfrica e esse documentário
era um teste de dna que determinou que a
minha estabilidade vem da tribo yorubá
da nigéria
e foi ali que eu aprendi que tudo que eu
sou não depende só disso depende de
muitas coisas que vieram muito antes de
mim então todas conectadas dentro de mim
obrigada
[Aplausos]